si todo el mundo sabe evacuar también
comenzo a ganar pero como saltar por detras
esto y aquí saldremos limpios
hasta que no tenga ganas de irse de Ilya
tengo que tengo miedo
pero el derecho de familia en casa me preocupa mucho
todo el tiempo a menudo
mientras que a menudo estábamos a salvo allí
más pasado
lo que tenemos para la producción es el segundo
frente segundo fondo porque muchos
minas del sector estatal para hoy
cerrado y la parte del león al timón que
utilizar nuestras centrales térmicas
Planta de energía térmica telépata ucraniana
obtienen en realidad de
presa del Donbass occidental, bueno, además
[música]